foreign
by the Tree of Life lives a honking
flock of pure pinkness I'm coming to
check on our lesser flamingos these guys
are from Africa
hi guys good morning
how are you doing
hi everybody
it's egg laying season for the Lesser
flamingos and the potential parents are
busy
but it hasn't always been this way
we've had absolutely no luck breeding
these birds we have had one chick in 20
years
[Music]
we always have a plan but in nature our
plan doesn't always fit in with reality
so sometimes that we can have what we
feel is a fantastic season lots of rain
lots of nest building but no eggs
it's a bad time for no breeding
all species of flamingos are under some
type of environmental pressure
out of all the species lessers are
probably the one that are the most
threatened at this time
they're feeling a lot of pressure in the
world in regards to habitat loss and
habitat destruction
to encourage more Romance the team looks
for ways to improve the habitat itself
the team decided they wanted to try
something different with the nesting
material
[Music]
[Applause]
it was an email that I received from
Animal Kingdom and it was a big surprise
Disney's Animal Kingdom asked if they
could borrow some baseball play for
their flamingos it's a special
combination of clay and sand that really
works well with this Florida climate
with the rain and the humidity it's
really malleable when it's wet but it
hardens really strongly when it's dry
and the birds just really took to it
containing more clay than Florida soil
the infield mix passed the flamingo nest
test
an egg appeared and then they were on a
roll
I don't know what's in this clay but
we're going to call it magic clay
because we're already at eggs five and
six
really excited we thought we had our
plan together and the flamingos are on
the same page
but only one egg proved fertile and for
the parents of that egg disaster struck
the father suffered from a leg injury so
we had to take him up to our Hospital
their processes the pear lays the egg
and then one incubates while the other
one eats and then they switch but the
mom couldn't raise the egg by herself
flamingos are serially monogamous so
with the biological parents down the
team looks for another solution that can
be found in nature in the wild it's not
uncommon for same-sex pairs to bond they
build these strong relationships that
can last for years we decided that our
best option was actually to give the egg
to our really great pair of male birds
foreign
sex pear blush and bashful swoop into
the rescue these two boys have been
together for a long time they've never
shown any interest in any of the females
that have come over to Discovery Island
we don't want to give the egg to the
other pairs because that would stop them
from possibly producing their own these
potential Deads quickly make a
connection with their new responsibility
the blush and bashful got the egg and
the whole time they were talking to the
egg which is very important it connects
them to the chick so they were making
that connection and building that Bond
the boys took the only fertile egg
safely under their caring Wings the
future of the flock now rests on them
we're hoping that instinct will kick in
and they'll know exactly what to do
thank you
[Music]